what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we got ourselves a trailer
for The Exorcist believer make me a make
me a gee Johnny how are you Johnny I am
ready to believe sir how are you I am
ready to believe as well ladies and
gentlemen leave your thoughts Down Below
on what you think about this trailer I
heard that some people did get to see
this trailer when it played before
Oppenheimer but because John and I we
were at our press screening for that
film we did not get a chance to see this
trailer yet but it is from David Gordon
green who obviously helmed the recent
Halloween Trilogy and this is supposed
to be a new Trilogy as well and the true
sequel to The Exorcist uh the original
film if I'm not mistaken Ellen Burson as
she is also reprising her role after we
watch it of course we will review it
let's see what's going on
also yeah quick plug I just got this out
of the mail uh are a soda shirts just
came in the mail for those Ahsoka Tano
fans however this shirt is literally
only gonna be available on the Zero
edition site till the end of July after
that it will no longer be available so
if you want to get yourself in a soda
shirt a great way to support the Channel
please go ahead and hit the link in the
description box all right let's watch
this
every day it'd be home by dinner I love
you hey Mr Fielding good morning morning
Catherine
Drop Zone it's metaphorical
about seven hours ago and that's the
last information we have Catherine
Angela if you can hear this we love you
please come home
interesting so it's a Daughter movie hey
hey you found her
we and Catherine doing out there in
those woods you're just walking and
walking so I remember
saw the Slender Man how long you were
gone a few hours
baby you've been gone three days
chilling you know 72 hours
I got a little Exorcist keep on the
music Tubular Bells what'd you say
I didn't say nothing
that's why I heard you say something
well at least you could pee in the
bathroom
oh they're both
wherever those girls went they brought
something back with them the body and
blood of Jesus Christ
foreign
but there are people out there
who have
Reagan
you pass back your nice match yes more
than I'd like
I believe you can help get our girls
back
exorcism eating the Bible yeah they all
use different methods
it's going to take all of them
[Music]
okay that's creepy
oh
cheese what did you do
[Applause]
[Music]
is that good makeup here
oh
jeez not bad
effect on the flash photography all
right John well what did you think of
this trailer what uh what Pros did you
find what Pros did you find here uh
I mean certainly this looks chilling and
it looks harsh and it looks demonic uh
and I mean you know you have one little
girl who sort of semi looks like Linda
Blair so that takes you right back along
with the you know present day Ellen
Burston the black girl yes the black
girl who looks just the spitting image
of Linda
um but yeah the story of a
father-daughter and then bringing in
Ellen burst and it makes sense to me
Leslie Odom Jr great actor uh I'm
excited to see what he brings to this it
definitely has some of that David girl
you know like if you've seen the
Halloween movies it feels like that
similar sort of
70s-esque style that doesn't 100 percent
say Exorcist to me but this has that
same sort of restraint to that the
original Exorcist seems to have it seems
like it's splitting the difference
between that more aggressive tone versus
the percolating and the you know
building ominous looming dread that just
you know sort of consumes as the movie
goes further
um but you know it's a kind of a heavy
Prospect to come back after so long and
be like nah this is the sequel to The
Exorcist especially after The Exorcist
sequels especially the third one have
garnered their own sort of love and
respect over time uh so I I you know I'm
part of me is cautiously optimistic part
of me is like
I wonder what is going to really set
this apart from a lot of other ghosts
and haunting and possession movies that
we've gotten lately that are all clearly
inspired by The Exorcist yeah yeah
um and yeah like there are certainly a
lot of images like I got most interested
by like some of the odd likes of dogs
fighting each other their car crashes
happening and this looks like it's gonna
span like deceptively further than the
contained focus of this trailer seems to
be implying but I'm not 100 sure
obviously it's just a trailer
um but but yeah I mean this is a bit of
a tall order and David Gordon green I
mean was one and a half out of three for
me in terms of like success rate on
those Halloween movies and this is an
even taller order I think because the
Exorcist Garners a lot more like
cinematic respect in a different way as
if you know film uh so the prospect of
coming in and being like this is the
sequel is a bit audacious to me but
we'll see how it goes yeah
yeah this feels like the Blum House Take
On The Exorcist it really does like I I
guess I was due to the and pre-hype that
this movie was getting uh I have not
actually seen any of those other
Exorcist movies I've only seen the
original when I was a child uh growing
up in Catholic School the film did
absolutely terrify me but yeah that
first Exorcist movie is a very long
movie if I'm not mistaken in it yeah
it's pretty character driven and there's
such a deliberate build up to the finale
with uh intermittently having a rather
terrifying moment or a terrifying scene
and some very iconic ones where here it
definitely has that accelerated uh
visceral punch to it that at times I was
very much intrigued by what we were
seeing on screen other times uh it
looked like a movie be that I would if
it wasn't called The Exorcist I would go
this looks like a movie that's trying to
be the exercise
and and then other times uh I
appreciated the way it was being shot
and other times it also kind of looked a
bit made for TV in a way and that might
have something to do with the fact that
they are uh trying to capture this in in
the framing of of like a 1970s movie yet
it's digitally shot so it doesn't quite
a translator to that but do you get what
I mean uh that it that that's what kind
of gives it a bit of uh of a made-for-tv
like a really good made for TV effect
because there's a lot of great you know
movies that are that go to streaming now
or something like that that uh obviously
look really good uh but I mean overall I
like the idea idea too of you know of
course bringing Ellen Burston back which
did give me more Insidious Vibes and
that's why I was getting uh impressions
of like this is like a Blum House uh The
Exorcist movie for sure and the concept
two of it being within uh two girls so
double the power
neat neat idea of something to add a
little bit of a Twist to it and of
course you know having some moments that
directly seem to Homage the original one
which does line up a little bit more
considering that this plot line is the
original demon is back
yeah they one that they want ex they're
out for revenge or something I don't
know what it is they're going for one
woman's Souls you gotta torture this
woman a little bit more yeah uh this one
feels like it it would be an
entertaining movie uh it it looks good
to me
um it doesn't look like sometimes you
watch it granted it is just a trailer
though uh so to me I am tempering my
expectations at this moment I I did like
David Gordon Green's uh first couple
Hollow I love his first Halloween movie
uh I like the second one and I I was not
a fan of his third one I was it was I
was in that camp you were I was not so I
was not a fan of that third one
and this to me I think kind of uh
warrants a little bit more of the David
Gordon Green from Halloween ends even
though I don't like that movie I'm like
but it's hot this is exorcist and it
kind of warrants a little bit more of
that David Corden green where you are
going for something that feels more
unique where this feels of uh currently
maybe the movie itself is actually like
very different in its execution but at
least with what they're advertising out
of a a very long trailer actually it
it's like oh this is this is a this
seems like pretty by the Numbers
it wants to be more Punchy than it wants
to be like you know suspenseful or
something like that it seems like it
wants to really get you in that
Insidious sort of like ah we're coming
at you a kind of aggressive Vibe yeah
yeah again just a trailer uh but at this
current moment in time yeah it does feel
a little bit more by the numbers than I
originally had uh hoped that we would
get for its first trailer yeah and I
mean too I'm always a little wary when
you're like we're coming back for the
legacy sequel and it's a Trilogy yeah
because you know I feel like Halloween
demonstrated that they kind of seem to
have gotten a little bit ahead of
themselves in that approach and this is
something that I think will require wire
and even steadier hand because again
you've got a more just everyone loves
the original Halloween and coming back
to that and everyone loves the original
Exorcist but they're different films and
one is certainly a much longer more
dramatic or sort of spiral of
deterioration kind of mood sure
um and so yeah I don't know this this
I'm curious to see how those split the
difference in tone and how they will
stretch this out over three movies when
the original Exorcist Trilogy yeah and
Beyond it already had you know kind of
its own struggles becoming a franchise
yeah I mean the acting looks good and
all uh so we'll see we'll see but what
did you guys think about the trailer I
wonder how this trailer actually plays
uh in a theater more than released on
YouTube so yeah just let us know your
thoughts down below uh be sure to
subscribe leave a like and hey we will
talk with you guys soon thank you so
much for being here
thank you